É porque no Brasil esses político é tudo
corrupto porque no Brasil esses político
é tudo corrupção e tu sabe o que é
corrupção desgraça APAE é porque vai ter
uma gincana na escola eu preciso comprar
a blusa da gincana Quanto é a blusa
20reais você fala para o teu pai quer 25
a verdade a blusa era 20 Você ficou com
a pele tanto fazer um trabalho da escola
e eu tenho que comprar um isopor até
isotomere é r$ 5 o corredor reais e
ficou com três sabe que é isso aí qual a
opção pega desvio de verba você acha que
de corrupção é dizer ao dinheiro da
merenda
E aí a pessoa faz desde pequena
corrupção pegando o dinheiro do pai
bicho Itabaiana no sol todo dia o
bichinho meu Deus me chupa chupa chupa
dinheiro do pai de reclamar que eu rouba
o dinheiro da merenda tomando a mas é
que eu só fazia isso na escola e
é
chegado começa da escola começa ele
pedir